separation
porn been something that we've been
talking about the last streams and let's
go ahead and do an entire stream on on
the
subject we got a bunch of imagery
of violence death destruction
nuclear weapons bombs
Jets nation
states arguing over
who gets what
lands who gets what
resources
contracts contracts
over over
separation it's it's all about the
separation it's all about me and
other it's what it's all
about it's about
wholeness which is nothing
everything it's about that which is
always a vacuity it's always empty and
it's always fulfilled and it's always
non-local it's about that being
contracted into the illusion of a
separate Center Point that is that has
enemies and then that separate Center
Point that has enemies is not only in
the form of nation states and um it's
also in the form of religion there's
plenty of warfare that happens over
religion
all of what's Happening
online in the
aggressive social media
dynamics of picking
sides and then shaming those who uh
disagree with you or don't agree with
you or calling them stupid or hating on
them that's also SE eration
porn so that would
be
yeah that would be
that and
meanwhile
there's the unconditional love that is
what everything is made of all of that
separation porn is made of unconditional
love
and the separation porn is
the
main uh attribute in a way of what keeps
the center point vortexing around its
conditioned beliefs and assumptions of
separation of others of hatred of
violence this one was this one was
absolutely
um oh I I haven't switched the
screen there we
go I mean this happens all the time but
it was just this is just so this is just
such a comedic version
of what we're discussing
here but it's just
this you know this in essence is a
separation
porn it's just military industrial
complexes that are absolutely out of
control that are made of unconditional
love that are totally out of
control and then those massive military
industrial complex as being huge parts
of the uh economic uh
GDP and therefore not wanting to be
decreased and then the O other
countries which are obviously the same
everything that come to these m massive
military industrial complexes and do
some sort of contractual
exchange and then get massive amounts of
the Weaponry so then they can go and be
safe or defend themselves or attack
their enemies in their local areas which
is again just a separation porn
illusion and it's not just these world
leaders
it's world leaders selling military
weaponry
contracts and there's all kinds of
negotiations for this weaponry
and and there's all kinds of summits
that happen and all kinds
of basically nothing looking at itself
talking to itself
non-locality with
itself
obviously duded in ah this is a center
point that is another and now there will
be as much as can be negotiated
for this country this race this
ethnicity this religion more for us
because we're the closest to God we're
the smartest we need
to be safe we
our fear loss
we hope for a brighter
future and that other those others
are less
than and so the whole thing is a
complete illusion it's unconditional
love manifest as such a unbelievable
illusion
and it'll never work it'll never
work separation porn will never work as
the way or the route to wholeness it'll
never work buying expanding military
industrial
complexes is not the pathway to
wholeness obviously it's already whol
and the way to it is obviously
through
the dissolution of that elusory Center
Point that's already not there into what
is already the whole so that the whole
cannot have military industrial
complexes because they're
obviously absolutely
useless until the point when the center
point is completely
unraveled
and and really recognizes the
individual's non-existence nothing
recognizing
that there will still be some sort of
Separation porn there will still be some
sort of drive to have military
industrial complex Weaponry there will
still be some sort of drive to create
all kinds of
borders and all kinds of passport
systems and vaccine systems and control
systems of media and
technology and oversight and daddy
government daddy daddy government
government Mommy Mommy supervise
supervise I'm incapable I'm incapable I
need to suck on the nipp
of the informational Matrix
complex and so
that's separation porn separation porn
is I am
real I'm living my
story and my story is in a world of
others which are different nations
they're different
people they're um out to get me they
have their own nuclear weapons and we
need to build up our nuclear
weapons
and it's a
constant fight for it's a constant
struggle for what's missing and what's
missing can be achieved through Warfare
through uh safety and security and in
mil military
complexes and it ends up being the most
inhumane the most unethical the most
immoral imaginable unconditional love is
most
immoral through the center
point through the elusory center point
unconditional freedom is most
unethical when contracted as an elery
Center
Point it just
absolutely absolutely without a doubt
does not
care it does not care and it's so
obvious and simple just look online and
see all the conversations about military
military complexes
Weaponry funding
Weaponry
um the the strong impenetrable belief
system that there are others that are
enemies and so that's where
all immorality and
unethical is is right there in that
center
point it's right there in the illusion
of the separate individual among
separate others and nation
states and there will never ever ever be
satisfaction on that path unconditional
love
manifest as a contracted Center Point is
on a pathway to try to find fulfillment
and wholeness by manipulating the
appearance using weapons of mass
destruction it'll never work it'll never
work the only way out of mutually
assured destruction with weapons of mass
destruction with countries that hate
each other and that are constantly in
contractual
negotiations um the only way out of that
is by unwinding or unraveling that
elusory Center Point that's not there in
the first place there's already no
difference between these countries
there's already no difference
between the bodies the bodies are all a
singularity OB
obviously
obviously and that's why it's separation
porn it's separation porn
because there's there's only there's
only wholeness there's only
unconditional
love and
the
the within the appearance of
that is that contracted Center Point and
the primary function of that contracted
Center Point is separation
porn so there's only wholeness only
unconditional love
and within
that is the appearance of a contracted
Center Point and the primary function of
that is separation
porn and then
wholeness through its other contracted
Center
points eats popcorn and watches that
separation porn picking sides
yelling at others that don't agree with
them
and
insatiably being
dissatisfied in
duality of self and others and inity of
what's right and wrong and inity of two
separate
Nations there's such absolutely elusory
boundaries
there's without a doubt and it's so
obvious because it's constantly pointed
to by cartographers and historians it's
just all of those boundaries that have
been made as nation states are just
obviously complete Illusions and what
will happen is sometimes there will be
these boundaries that are made and it
will literally be cutting a a
a a tribe or culture or whatnot in half
into two different country identities so
now there's the same
people this the bodies that like the
same kinds of
preferences that are now affiliated with
two different nationalities or countries
and so their passports belong to these
two different countries and now they
have another identifier or attribute
which is just an assumption which now
that they can War
over and that's separation
porn comment in the live chat about jazz
Vidant that's so
funny yeah in a way this is like uh
nonuel jazz or adite to Jazz sure
nonuel
Jazz yeah it is kind of like non-el jazz
it's like
music it's like
music
um that's cutting cutting
Duality yeah and it's so fun it's so um
yeah it just feels really like Flow full
and and and fun and
playful and and it's been a while
there's been so much like straight
jacketing for this body and it's just
completely being obliterated and it's
just everything that
has um wanted to be said authentically
flowy is finally just
unbridled flowing
through
and because there's just too much of a
there's too much
regret and there's too much
um
uh um uh non
authenticity really by uh repressing and
no one is controlling or doing that but
it's quite clearly seen by no one when
there is more of a of a straight jacket
that is that is that is there that oh my
God I I can't I can't talk about this I
can't I can't have my nipples on
camera I can't I can't talk like this or
the nonsense
stuff it just doesn't matter it just
doesn't matter and there's freedom in it
not mattering the ultimate unconditional
freedom is in that unbounding of that
straight jacket and allowing the body to
naturally spontaneously authentically
Express itself exactly as it's destined
to be and so that's clearly what's
flowing and it's beautiful it's
beautiful and it just there's no longer
that mattering when doesn't mattering
becomes obvious to no one to nothing
then it can flow
unobstructed
naturally that Timeless
non-local
preciousness and ordinariness that is
this body's natural spontaneous
beingness its
vibrancy cuz this is its natural
vibrancy its natural vibrancy is to be
is to literally pull stuff up like this
and just be like isn't this [__]
[__] isn't it beautifully [__]
[__] that's this is natural vibrancy
to just poke fun at how absolutely
[__] this
is it just it just doesn't it just
doesn't matter it doesn't
matter this is so
funny oh this shit's funny as
[__] yeah that that's exactly that's
exactly it yes yes uh separate nation
states with Incredible military
industrial complexes that have no
problem with using these weapons to kill
innocent civilian
and have no problem being
justified no problem being justified
with with not only dropping it on on
citizens that
are
completely Innocent but also have no
problem with uh H having this Mirage
perception of another and then
propagating that Mirage Mirage
perception of another
onto its uh people in its country
through its media industrial complex so
the media industrial complex is the way
that separation porn propagates through
uh nation state
identity the media industrial complex is
the way that separation porn propagates
through
a nation state
identity is so [__]
fascinating it's completely
mind-blowing it's like a
uh it's like unconditional love and
freedom
being appearing to be contracted in that
center point of me has all of these
different tools and modalities to be
able to proliferate separation porn and
to further contract and reify the
illusion of of separation and enemies
and the need of warfare and
and uh resource pillaging and murdering
innocent
people there's so much uh yeah the
desens
desensitization of uh these um uh
military industrial complexes and uh and
engineers and um technologist and uh
designers and those that are involved in
it in uh the in
governance in in the politics because
one one has to be extremely um
desensitized and dehumanized in order to
continue to um build Technologies and
weaponry that further reify the illusion
of separation and murdering of innocent
non-
entities that's just it
that's just it you there's nowhere
there's nowhere to go
but really as nothing seeing separation
porn as
this
massively contracted complex that is all
about others and it's all about
militaries and nation states and war and
violence and more for me less for you my
people are smarter than your people my
people are better than your people my
people are closer to God than your
people your people are savages my people
are
Saints follow us on social media make
sure to retweet us on social media make
sure to change your profile picture on
social media to include our
flag that is such a fascinating
manipulation tactic of the contracted
separation porn
energy is is uh take your profile
picture and add our flag that you have
no affiliation with
whatsoever the person The non- Entity
the body that is adding or slapping a
flag a country's flag onto its profile
picture usually has no connection
whatsoever to the roots of that uh
country or area it has usually no
friends that have uh that have uh their
ethnicity is from that
area and it has no prior research or
understanding of the culture or the
history uh of that area in its uh
nuance and so therefore it's just a
puppet
it's just a puppet for the separation
porn industrial complex
[__] [__]
[__] that's what it is it's just [__]
it's separation porn industrial complex
propagating this meme which is you're a
bad person if you don't add this flag to
your profile
picture and then there's that feeling of
Shame oh I must conform I must oblig to
what my government or my group is
doing and so that's how all of these
uh beautiful vomity
dynamics that are all made of
unconditional freedom and love that's
how they all
appear That's Just the story but that's
apparently how they
appear this is ridiculous
this image is so ridiculous yeah
yeah presidents of nation states ucer
bounded nation states with weapons to
murder kill it's just so
ridiculous such a funny ass
one yeah there's just no
no like it's just everyone all these all
nation states are
just
after the illusion of of separation and
acquiring military weaponry there are
certain nation states that are um that
are definitely more um
anti- separation porn which
is equally as
beautiful and there's no value
system cuz it's just what
is but those nation states that are less
Nation stady they're more uh wholeness
and then they're less military
industrial complex they're more
wholeness sharing caring
loving building
Dowing Earth its basic needs freeing
people
Etc that is a beacon in a way for what
uh what this is like without a me
without a center
point so
this without a center point which is
what it always is it effortlessly
manifests as the obliteration of nuclear
weaponry and mutually assured
destruction and
the the obliteration of Separation
porn and it's very uncomfortable to talk
about the obliteration of Separation
porn to the contracted center point of
me because the primary way that that
contracted center point of me lives the
primary way that it
thrives is through separation
porn through the elusory projection of
another through the
Neurosis of hatred of
other through the Neurosis of being for
military industrial complexes and
nuclear weaponry and killing innocent
civilians
yeah so it attaches me attaches to its
to its knowing cloud
of of Separation
porn and then becomes like an
impenetrable
Fortress because it
knows it's
unknowing knowing separation porn that's
another great way to say
it
unknowing knowing separation
porn emptiness Center pointing
contracted in separation porn nothing
contracted in separation
porn nothing knowing cloud of Separation
porn
wholeness
meing in separation
porn yeah I mean that's the most direct
simple easy way to say it wholeness
meing in separation porn what is
non-local and non- entity is meing
contracted Center pointing with this
knowing cloud of Separation porn and
neurotic
knots there's already no
entity that makes up that knowing cloud
of Separation porn there's already no
entity inside the
body and that's why it's
non-u it's just an apparent
dreamed experience of a Center Point
point and it's not even worth mentioning
when nothing clearly sees that it was
never there that that Center Point was
never
real it's not even worth
mentioning it's the sense of me is such
a thin and
fragile
contracted illusion
and it's both with its massive Fortress
of impenetrability and yet it's so
freaking
Fragile the knowing Cloud can seem so
massive and impenetrable but it's so
fragile when it's reflected you don't
exist you're not
real there's only non-local no
thingness and it just
crumbles as fast
fascinating
a pretty
day
sky and
[Music]
clouds the
trees tracking
off
[Music]
well yeah
that's that's pretty much it on
the current of Separation porn
fun
to just roar
that so
fun and so obvious it's just
unbelievably obvious that separation
porn is the primary function of me of
knowing which is made of
Unknowing it's made of nonlocal
nothingness it's
crazy just a
sheer ah
just there's
no care at all
for the everything
thinging cuz what's more important than
the everything is that contracted ucer
me and its knowing cloud and its belief
systems and so then it doesn't care
about killing other
bodies it's just fascinating it's so
simple ordinary it's fun to give it a
name it's useful in a way to give it a
name not that there's some sort
of
intention it's just fun to give it a
name it's like part of the the
play that it all is is to give it a
name like oh all these things combined
these militaries this separation this me
the center point it's all like
separation
porn these internet yelling
arguments the the murders on
videos it's all separation porn it's
like a separation porn industrial
complex
SP separation porn industrial
complex it's
like the way you go on a porn
site
um this is the equivalent of when you go
on a new site when you go on a new site
you're watching porn but separation
porn so instead instead of watching
people
[__] you're
watching uh people
killing or inflicting
pain and that's separation
porn so there's
a there's a
promulgation a continuation of the
Paradigm that is the spirit or the
separation porn industrial complex by
just tuning into
those new the news that is feeding the
separation
porn I'm not even sure of
any news
that is constantly cutting the duality
of Separation
porn
so if there is true obvious no thing
everything then the body naturally just
is gravitated
to cutting the
dualities because the body is just
interested in simple ordinary
everyday basic needs being met Freedom
Joy play laughter
and when there's all this geopolitical
tension the body can't in a way as
easily rest and relax when the culture
around it is just in its own Center
points of
arguments and all this content about
that's being produced about World War II
and
whatnot all of that just further all of
these opinions that are separation porn
all of them just further promulgate the
idea or the notion that the way out of
Separation porn which is already an
illusion is
[Music]
through uh killing the other or
um some sort of violence towards the
other or some sort
of attempt at a peace agreement between
two separate Nations and that's not it
it's not it's not a it's not agreement
between separate Nations it's the
recognition by nothing that everything
is
sameness there will there will not be a
way to peace agreement to
wholeness it'll
only happen longterm through
non-locality it'll only happen longterm
through non-
eness through only
wholeness when these different
apparently different nation
states when there's a a clear
recognition by no one that there is only
everything there's only wholeness then
that is an
effortless natural and spontaneous
dawing of
Earth otherwise it is just at the level
of the symptoms within that little me
that little Center Point with other
Center points of different nation states
trying to make
agreements so whether it's dropping
bombs or trying to make agreements from
those Center points M never
work
it will only work long term through
nothing clearly recognizing that there's
only wholeness there's only non-local
everything
yep and that's the
Dow that's
dawing non-local everything is Dow it's
obvious spontaneous Natural Body
dawing and that's not another it's not
another straight jacket it's not another
box because it's actually the boxless
that natural dawing is completely
boxless anything
goes anything goes but when there's no
longer a mi there's no longer a center
point there is no longer that othering
and there's no longer that killing
there's no longer
that there's no longer separation
porning there's just no more straight
jacket it's just Pure Freedom It's Just
Pure
Freedom and DOW is
a a clear natural spontaneous way of
freedom freedom for all
bodies be
abundant be prosperous create play Sing
dance
love Harmony
nature laugh
it's just too simple it's too too too
too
simple there is a Obsession in the
separation porn complexity and it's all
made of simple ordinary unconditional
wholeness Love Freedom non-local
everything it's made of that and it's
just too simple and too
ordinary and that simple and
ordinariness is what Dows and those
Center points are what upset about
separation porn and drop
bombs
nice all
right we'll wrap this one up and
probably be back later today with
another stream
ski all right thanks for tuning in
fam that unconditional love and freedom
that's always
already
here always already here
never been lost can't be
found it's already what is appearing as
everything and that fun cutting of
Separation
porn
all
right see you
later